president joe biden is expected to sign
an executive order this week around
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies there's a
lot of people freaking out about this
but before you lose your mind let's make
sure we understand exactly what is
expected to happen if we go ahead and we
take a look what we can see is that
there's an article from bloomberg that
describes the order will direct federal
agencies to examine potential regulatory
changes as well as the national security
and economic impact of digital assets
said the people who asked not to be
named discussing these deliberations if
we then look at the actual directives
inside of this order we expect that it
will direct the treasury the state
department and the attorney general to
study cbdc's or central bank digital
currencies it will ask the fsoc to study
financial stability of crypto it'll also
ask people to look at digital asset
impact to market competition and it will
direct the sec and the cftc to look at
market protection as well now of course
people are freaking out about this but
if we look at the expectation or the
impact on crypto what we can see is
these three things where crypto's role
is a challenge to national security i
don't necessarily agree with that but
that is one expectation that it's a
threat to the dominance of the dollar
again i do not agree with that but that
is one of the expectations and lastly
that it adds difficulty in stopping
criminal activity which again i don't
agree with but that is an expectation of
what many people think the reports will
actually come forward with we then have
this quote here which shows that him das
the acting director of treasuries
financial crimes enforcement network
said although we have not seen
widespread evasion of our sanctions
using methods such as cryptocurrency
prompt reporting of suspicious activity
contributes to our national security and
our efforts to support ukraine and its
people now of course as more and more
people start to freak out about this
executive order you have to remember two
important things one it simply asks very
organizations across the government to
do studies to go and look do your work
do your research figure out what is
bitcoin what are cryptocurrencies what
are their impact on markets regulations
and other aspects that the government
cares about that isn't a good or a bad
thing it's simply asking them to go
gather more information and understand
what the impact is and then second is
regardless of what these reports
actually come out and show what we have
to remember is that bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are actually a good
thing for the world they don't threaten
the dollar's dominance they actually
strengthen the dollar's dominance they
don't help criminals actually help law
enforcement catch the criminals who
decide to use an open transparent
immutable ledger to commit crimes over
and over and over again we've seen
critiques and criticisms from various
people around the world on these
technologies but over and over and over
again we continue to educate people we
continue to simply present the facts of
what's going on in the industry how the
technology works and what the market
participants are doing with these
technologies and what continues to
happen is we strike down
criticism after criticism after
criticism bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
are good for business bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies give power to people
it's the most american technology in the
world right now it's all about
sovereignty it's all about individual
responsibility it's all about personal
freedom and free speech there's nothing
more american than that and what i hope
happens is that the various
organizations within the us government
not only come back and highlight all of
those different details but also they
put forward recommendations that the
united states must jump in the game we
have to be the leader in this new
technology it leads to innovation
economic prosperity and economic benefit
if anyone's going to benefit from these
technologies i hope it's the united
states hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time